[Music]
bft on yahoo sports peter king mike
florio talking about the big stories in
the nfl and look one of the things that
we pay attention to peter all season
long
mvp candidates who's in the mix who's in
the running well we've got 25
percent of the season now played with
the exception of the titan steelers game
so let's go through our top three mvp
candidates so far i'll let you go first
well mike here we are the nfl at the
quarter pole
and as i look at this i am absolutely
shocked that there's a quarterback of a
4-0 team
who's played great who has not thrown an
interception
and is in one of the best four game
stretches of his career
has won an mvp has won a super bowl mvp
and he's not in my top three
that's the insanity of all this and
you have to do so much nuance when you
do the mvp
and the reason why i'm picking number
one russell wilson
number two aaron rodgers and number
three josh allen
there's a reason for that and it has to
do
in part not only they're all four and oh
but i think they're
all performing above the expectation
that anybody would normally have for
them aaron rodgers because of his
you know robert tanyan is his big star
you know russell wilson because he has
virtually played
perfect football his quarterback rating
is about 9
he's completing 75 percent and josh
allen
is has become a complete quarterback
before our very eyes and so that would
be my top three but honestly mike
if you put those in any order or you put
patrick mahomes in there i'd be
absolutely fine with it
yeah i'm gonna go russell wilson patrick
mahomes and aaron rodgers and
peter i'm influenced by a couple of
things we've talked in the past about
how
at the end of the day at the end of the
season the teams that get the buys
those are the teams whose quarterbacks
are going to attract more votes when
it's time for the 50 human beings
to cast their ballots and they're going
to be influenced by that who's the one
seed in the afc
i think the chiefs have a better chance
of being the one seed than the bills
that's why mahomes is my guy and in the
nfc i look at
the seahawks and the packers one of
those two teams is going to be the one
seed
one of those two quarterbacks is going
to be the mvp candidate it's that simple
and mahomes has that name recognition
mahomes has that sizzle mahomes is the
guy right now
and it's just his mere presence that
makes a team better even if josh allen
has better stats at the end of the day
the fact that mahomes has been an nfl
regular season mvp
a super bowl mvp that's going to win him
votes
from the 50 people are going to have to
decide who are we going to put
at the ballot and i s it still pet
peeves
beyond the use of quarter pole pet peeve
for me the fact that it's one person one
vote
for this it needs to be like the heisman
first place second place
i would agree but but i'll tell you this
mike you know uh i hope
that if i ever include the factors
sizzle or star power
uh when i consider i'm not saying you
would please
i'm not sending me off the committee i'm
not saying i'm not saying you're saying
i'm saying that that never i i've never
heard
anybody say well jeez a lot of sizzle
with patrick mahomes
and if anybody tries to say that they
need to be thrown off
i i agree i'm trying to anticipate the
behavior of the collective group of
50 and i know and i'm not going to name
names there are people on that committee
who shouldn't be
and so i'm trying to factor that into
this as we're tabulating these votes
one person one vote and somebody's going
to be influenced by factors they
shouldn't be influenced by that's my
point that's how i'm handicapping this
this isn't this isn't anything that's
ever going to be decided
objectively it's always going to be
subjective and you have to
just like when you go to court you got
to know the judge you got to know the
jury you got to know the 50
and you got to understand how they
operate you wouldn't do it others would
that's why it's a factor for me
the fact that there's only one uh
buy team now i'm not voting for the best
player on a buy
team i mean he's got a good chance to
win it
but this may be the year for the first
year in a while that i
split my vote with two quarterbacks at
the top
he's peter king i'm mike floria we'll
see you next time for more pft
on yahoo
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit
subscribe for the latest news and
highlights from nbc sports